sciences bonjour et bienvenue dans ce
top sciences intitulé notre évolution au
quotidien il paraîtrait qu'il est
impossible de voir l'évolution car elles
savent gérer d'un processus trop lent et
une vie entière ne suffiraient pas et
pourtant chaque année la grippe revient
plus virulents watch et de nouvelles
variétés apparaissent s'adaptant à
l'homme alors qu'elle était porcine ou
aviaire et que dire des insectes
résistants pesticides divertir
résistante aux antibiotiques ou encore
des mauvaises herbes résistantes aux
herbicides ou bien encore katata voter
bon c'est bon on a compris l'idée l'a
donc l'évolution ça se voit à part la
nôtre qui est un peu plus lente mais
saviez vous que vous côtoyez notre
révolution au quotidien laissez-nous
vous narrer 4 milliards d'années
d'évolution en à peine 24 heures
certains qu'on vous lever le matin vous
accomplissez ce noble geste ancestral
qui est de se redresser et qui cas mais
n'ont pas su à lèves toi voyons
ce geste ancestral donc de vous mettre
debout une chose que nos ancêtres
hominidés ont commencé à faire il ya
presque 10 millions d'années de cela et
vous attrapez ensuite un bol de café
un geste qui peut être accompli grâce à
votre pouce opposable que vous avez
hérité de l'ancêtre commun à tous les
primates
apparu il ya pas moins de 60 millions
d'années vous vous brossez aussi
certainement les dents et si vous devez
les entretenir c'est parce que vous n'en
aurez pas d'autres contrairement aux
ricains et aux crocodiles dont les dents
se renouvelle sans cesse
ce renouvellement dentaire limitée
caractérise les mammifères
un groupe dans les plus anciens à eux
sont apparus à peu près en même temps
que les dinosaures il y a environ 240
millions d'années
vous remarquerez aussi que les manifs
air sur le seul groupe d'animaux
possédant des poils donc vous pourrez
penser à nous quand vous vous frotterez
puis une fois au travail je disais au
travail vous vous êtes servi de vos
doigts ses doigts dont la présence nous
semble si anodines ne sont toutefois
apparues qui lie à 350 millions d'années
chez un groupe qu'on nomme vulgairement
les amphibiens et qui a donné naissance
à tous les tétrapodes ce groupe comporte
aussi les oiseaux et les reptiles et oui
les écrans ça fatigue les yeux et
d'ailleurs ces yeux là sont très
différents d'un ceci et cela
et ses yeux nous les avons hérité de
notre dernier ancêtre aquatique qui
était aussi dense être de tous les
vertébrés est il vécu il ya de cela cinq
cent millions d'années
elle habite je vois que vous mangez avec
votre bouche
mais saviez vous que si vous étiez une
mouche ou mangeriez que votre anus
et oui car chez les mouches deux
premiers trous qui se forme dans
l'embryon deviendra la bouche alors que
chez l'homme le premier trou qui se
forme dans l'embryon deviendra l'anus
pardon voilà c'est bien l'annus les
seuls invertébrés qui partage avec nous
la même polarité de l'embryon sont les
étoiles de mer et les oursins chez eux
comme chez nous la bouche apparaît en
deuxième et c'est pourquoi nous formons
avec eux le groupe d2t rostomia apparu
il ya 800 millions d'années
la journée a été longue et vous avez
bien mérité de vous coucher pour poser
vos neurones les mêmes neurones partagé
par tous les animaux de la méduse à
l'escargot en passant par l'oursin et
non mauvais exemple les neurones et le
système nerveux qui va avec sont apparus
chez l'ancêtre de tous les animaux il y
à un milliard d'années
6 pas le temps pour le sexe pas de bol
mais attendez peut-être ne seriez vous
pas contre quelques foot vous accomplir
y ait un seul geste fondamental de la
vie définition même du vivant la
reproduction car assurer sa descendance
et transmettre ces jeunes a été la
condition sinequanone de l'existence de
tous les êtres vivants qu'ils soient
arbres bactéries champignons ou animaux
et ce depuis l'apparition de la première
cellule vivante
il y a quatre milliards d'années
cette option se termine merci de l'avoir
suivi nous espérons vous avoir
convaincus que l'évolution est visible à
échelle humaine et que vous la
fréquenter absolument tous les jours
pour en savoir plus nous vous
conseillons la lecture de la
classification phylogénétique du livre
ou bien encore le dvd espèces d'espèces
merci à tous